E
TO PICK UP NINE SEATS SO FAR IN
THE HOUSE?
I DON'T KNOW.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY IS POISED TO TAKE
NANCY'S GAVEL THOUGH AND
"PRIMETIME" EXPECTS HIM TO START
WIELDING HIS POWER RIGHT AWAY.
WILL THERE BE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE BIDEN CRIME FAMILY, THE
ORIGINS OF COVID AND OUR WIDE
OPEN SOUTHERN BORDER?
WE HOPE SO.
BUT RUMORS OUT OF WASHINGTON ARE
SUGGESTING THAT BECAUSE OF THIS
RAZOR THIN MARGIN, IS HE GOING
TO HAVE HIS HANDS FULL WITH THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS KEVIN McCARTHY
JOINS US NOW FOR HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE THE MIDTERM
ELECTION.
I WILL CALL YOU SPEAKER TO GET
IT OUT OF THE WAY.
SPEAKER, TELL US WHAT HAPPENED A
6 MILLION VOTE MARGIN, NO ONE
PREDICTED THAT.
BUT THE HOUSE PICK-UPS AREN'T AS
BIG AS PEOPLE THOUGHT?
>> WELL, IF YOU LOOK AT IT, WHAT
WAS OUR MISSION?
TO WIN THE MAJORITY, TO STOP
BIDEN'S AGENDA AND FIRE NANCY
PELOSI ALL OF THAT IS
ACCOMPLISHED.
YOU ARE CORRECT.
6 MILLION MORE VOTES AS OF
TODAY.
A HIGHER PER SEAN DAMAGE OF THE
OVERALL VOTE WE HAD IN 2010 WHEN
WE PICKED UP 63 SEATS.
WHAT YOU REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
IN 2010 SITTING AT 178.
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS, WE ARE
THE ONLY REPUBLICANS TO WIN.
WHEN EVERYBODY THOUGHT WE WOULD
LOSE THE LAST CYCLE, WE PICKED
UP 14.
AGAIN, WE WILL PICK UP THIS TIME
AS WELL.
REMEMBER, IN THE HOUSE, THEY
DON'T GIVE GAVELS OUT BY SMALL,
MEDIUM AND LARGE.
THEY JUST GIVE YOU THE GAVEL.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GOVERN.
ON THAT VERY FIRST DAY, AFTER
BEING SWORN IN, WE WILL REPEAL
87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS AND SEND
THAT TO THE SENATE.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE COMING OUT OF
THE GATE STRONG.
TELL ME ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET THE TRUTH OUT
HERE.
THIS STUFF WITH BIDEN AND CHINA
AND UKRAINE AND THE BANKING
RECORDS.
THE TREASURY WIRE REPORTS WE GOT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S GOING ON
HERE.
THAT'S A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW ABOUT THAT.
ARE YOU ON BOARD?
, 100 PERCENT.
ALREADY STARTED THAT AND
INFORMATION TO BE KEPT.
YOU WILL FIND THAT JIM JORDAN
WILL BE CHAIRMAN OF JUDICIARY.
YOU HAVE COMER CHAIRMAN OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
HOUSE TO HOLD THE GOVERNMENT TO
BE ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT MEANS WITH YOUR TAX
DOLLARS, THAT MEANS WHAT'S GOING
ON.
WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHERE THE
ORIGINS OF COVID BEGAN?
WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
THOSE LAST 60 DAYS OF
AFGHANISTAN SO WE NEVER HAVE 13
GOLD STAR FAMILIES AGAIN?
AND WHY DON'T WE KNOW WHY THE
DOJ WENT AFTER PARENTS AND
CALLED THEM TERRORISTS BECAUSE
THEY SIMPLY WANTED TO GO TO
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING AND HAVE A
SAY IN THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION.
THAT'S THE START OF THE ABILITY
WOE HAVE AT ACCOUNTABILITY.
REMEMBER, WITH THAT GAVEL,
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF HOW
HIGH OR OVER 218 YOU ARE, YOU
HAVE SUBPOENA POWER AND WE WILL
USE IT.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT CALLED
YOU ON THE PHONE.
HOW DID THAT GO.
>> IT WAS KIND OF SHORT.
HE CONGRATULATED ME.
SO FOR ANYONE WHO THINKS WE
DIDN'T WIN THE MAJORITY.
JOE BELIEVES WE DID AS WELL.
>> Jesse: WAS IT A CIVIL
CONVERSATION?
YOU GUYS ARE REALLY GOING TO
TURN UP THE HEAT.
HE MUST KNOW THAT.
>> YEAH, IT WAS SHORT.
HE JUST WANTED TO CALL ME,
CONGRATULATE FROM THAT POINT,
TALK ABOUT WHERE WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
LOOK, I SAID I WILL WORK WITH
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO PUT
AMERICA FIRST AND MOVE US IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT'S
FAILING.
WE HAVE GOT A CHALLENGE WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
WE NOT ONLY SHOULD BE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
WE SHOULD BE SELLING OUR NATURAL
GAS TO OUR ALLIES BUT ALSO TO
OUR ADVERSARIES.
WHY DON'T WE MAKE CHINA
DEPENDENT ON US?
WE NEED TO SECURE OUR BORDER.
I LAID THIS ALL OUT TO THE
PRESIDENT AND TOLD THEM I WILL
WORK WITH YOU IF YOU ARE WILLING
TO WORK ON THESE ITEMS.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD YOU DIDN'T
SEND TO TO VOICE MAIL LIKE THE
SAUDIS DID.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR
RIGHT FLANK?
THERE HAS BEEN SOME TURBULENCE
OVER THERE ABOUT HANDING THE YOU
THE GAVEL.
WHAT'S YOUR PLAY THERE.
>> I'M NOT CONCERNED.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
SINCE I HAVE BEEN LEADER FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS WE HAVE ONLY
GAINED SEATS.
IT'S THE GOAL OF WINNING THE
MAJORITY.
WE WON THE MAJORITY.
I THINK I ACCOMPLISHED THE GOAL
THAT WE WANTED TO.
WE WANT TO HAVE A VERY OPEN
PROCESS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A SMALLER
MAJORITY.
WE ARE GOING TO FIND THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER.
THINK ABOUT WHAT ELSE WE DID.
NOT ONLY WE WON THE MAJORITY WE
BEAT THE DCCC CHAIR THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED IN 42 YEARS.
WE WON SEATS THAT BIDEN WON BY
1.
WE WON IN NEW YORK AND OREGON
AND CALIFORNIA AND TEXAS, WE WON
ACROSS THIS NATION.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
ULTIMATE NUMBER YOU ARE GOING TO
HIT IN THE HOUSE IS GOING TO BE
AFTER YOU FINISH COUNTING.
>> WE WILL SEE WHEN THEY FINISH
COUNTING I THINK WE WILL PICK UP
MORE SEATS IN CALIFORNIA.
QUAKY PORTER IS A SEAT I BELIEVE
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE WIN.
WE HAVE NEW STAR FROM JEN
KIGGANS IN VIRGINIA BEACH.
DELACRUZ.
JOHN JAMES WESLEY HUNT IN
HOUSTON.
THIS PARTY HAS EXPANDED LIKE WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THESE ARE NEW, FRESH FACES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ROCK STARS IN
THE REPUBLIC